quel est votre pire saint-valentin votre
meilleur isabelle hier saint valentin on
était très encore plus jeunes avec mon
mari c'était a répété marine
non mais c'est alors vous êtes vieille
un soir de saint valentin il céder tiens
si on essayait le préservatif un
préservatif
nous n'avons jamais me ressemble on va
acheter un truc qui se trouve en
allemagne des préservatifs avec la tête
de mickey
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
plus que jamais une question les
oreilles voilà la lourdeur des vraies
petites oreilles lui fournissez le reste
est vraiment arrivé pas compris un truc
c'est bien rire ses vêtements il en
utilise et pas il l'a déroulé d'abord un
ajout aux marionnettes parce que
franchement